Greetings everybody, my name is Sam Dider and I'm a senior Unreal Engine instructor with Epic Games.
In the following video tutorial series, we're going to be taking a look at creating your first Unreal Engine project for games.
And what that is going to entail is we're first going to take a look at Unreal Engine 5, just a quick recap,
by looking at the user interface, viewport navigation, and working with actors,
just to refresh us on how these systems work as we're going to be using them to create some new levels.
Which brings us to the next part of this tutorial series, levels.
We're then going to talk about level concepts and how we create levels,
as levels are a key component of any Unreal Engine 5 project.
Then we're going to move on to the exercise portion or the hands-on portion of this.
This is going to entail us first taking a look at the project we're going to be working with.
We're then going to look at how we set up an initial level.
Then we'll take a look and add some actors to that level.
We'll then add some visual effects as well as some background props to really bring the level to life.
Then once we're done with all of that, we'll go over how we can publish this level to windows,
so that when we're done we have an executable that can be given to anyone that can play our project.
We've got a lot to cover, so let's go ahead and get started with our Unreal Engine 5 recap.